Thank you so much. Let's go next to our color
from the four, eight, four area code. Who's
calling today from four, eight, four.
Hello?
Yeah, that's you.
Oh, Hey David. Um, I'm Steven of calling from
the Pennsylvania.
Hey Steven, if you can speak up or get closer
to your phone, that would be great.
Hello? No, yes, that's much better. Um, so
my concern is that, well, Trump was, um, he
has some sort of interview or press conference,
I'm talking about Afghanistan and he was bragging
that you can wipe out s can stand out of a,
you know, uh, of the face of the earth within
10 days. Yeah. My concern is he this so casually
more information about our, you know, not
only, um, no, uh, you know, our opponents
in the Middle East, but also there are plans
for Russia and other, you know, countries
around the world of this is how we can, you
know, defeat, um, China for example, within
two weeks, something like that. So my concern
is if he's out of office, I was like, what,
what do you think the chances are that he
can casually say, oh yeah, I remember while
I was president, we can, you know, we were
able to, we could take pretty much any country
within a couple of weeks. You know what I
mean?
I don't know what you mean by if he's out
of office and he says that, I, I, so for people,
but the comments are outrageous for people
who don't know. Donald Trump, uh, said that
if he wanted, he could have Afghanistan wiped
off the face of the earth, but that he didn't
want to kill 10 million people in doing it,
which is an insane, absolutely insane thing
to say. It is. It strikes me as a sort of
flippantly indifferent to the possible mass
murder of millions and millions of people.
And you're completely right that the casual
nature with which he said it for me reminded
me of. I thought we were told that it was
Hillary who was a risk for getting us into
wars and bloodthirsty and all of that stuff.
Whereas we know Trump has considered war with
who knows how many countries at this point.
And it's casually mentioned. If you wanted
Afghanistan to disappear as a country, he
could do it. So my concern is not about when
he's out of office, what he'll say. My concern
is right now.
Right. Um, however, for example, he has information
about, you know, top secret, you know, officials
in areas around the world in those where spies
are located. And, um, if I'm a reporter, I
leave last year he shared a photo of um, seal
a seal team six or something. Yeah. And keyword
saying, you're sharing me doing that. You
just literally blew their location. And they
were like, you know, elite, you know, soldiers,
you know, doing, having certain operations,
you know.
Yes. He did do that. Yeah, that's true.
Yeah,
he did do that. Yeah.
So, so he did I, as far as I know this is
his second time revealing what is pretty much
no Sassy of your clients.
I don't think it's toxic. No, I don't agree
with you there. I don't think Trump revealed
any until he didn't say we have the plan of
wiping Afghanistan off. And I think anyone
who just knows how many nukes we have knows
that from like a logistical perspective we
could blow up the entire country. That's true.
So I don't agree with you that Trump revealed
anything classified by alluding to his bloodlust
uh, when it comes to to Afghanistan. But I
just think it was extremely concerning thing
for him to say, particularly how he said it.
Right. But again, if he was, if he was talking
about logistics for nuclear weapons for example,
that is literally something that can take
less than half an hour to do and cause cause
you know, of, you know, a nuclear weapon testing,
not to mention there are right now they are
a NICU or submarines in the area around the
Middle East, um, in the Pacific Ocean, Atlantic
Ocean. Um, so, um, based on the research I've
done, it takes about 15 minutes of flight.
Like how far, like if it was to be washed
from the u s they will take about 15 minutes
just to get some Moscow for example.
Okay. I don't know those numbers and I'm not
sure where you're going with it, but, but
the comments were very, very concerning and
I appreciate the call. Steven, I'm going to
move on. I'm not sure where we're going with
that last piece, but I'm glad you're paying
attention to what Donald Trump is saying.
Let me take a quick break. If you're holding,
don't hang up because I will go right back
to you just after this